the Dutch city of ain't over is home to
leading technology firms a famous
Technical University and a cutting-edge
fiber network yet it's far smaller
neighbor claims to have the highest
broadband uptake in the world welcome to
newnan I her francia in the neighborhood
and they Skype to me yeah we can see the
face from my my friends in the
neighborhood our society's confident
wish the last problem that's aiding
population effect we started this
project for the elderly you can imagine
that especially elderly under dead the
very old grandmother's and grandfathers
until halogens old can't leave their
homes I know people grandfather's
grandmother's living alone and their
children at the last distance and they
have daily contact today mr. children
via Skype and in the asked them people
say that it brings enormous quality to
the lives and in their relationship mr.
children and cultural my young yonas
thought of these living in the Bahamas
half every day contact list of children
and sometimes i am talking in arvin hour
sometimes 10 minutes that is marvelous
that contact to have vista children we
have built for thrown his own fido metal
when he wants to visit his daughter in
the Bahamas the only thing has to do is
take the final metal and this in some
seconds he has contact with his daughter
in Bahamas it is almost a life visit
in the same way we have to connect him
to his dr to official to the pastry
stadium you like soccer now one can see
and talk to his family whenever he likes
and that's not all thanks to ultra fast
fibers they can skype and watch their
favorite team together all at the same
time today and in the next future
unlimited bandwidth is needed by every
household the shins of newnan can
exactly describe how to live their lives
in future they won't live in the penalty
they don't affect what they say is we
want to die in our own home we don't
want to go to houses for elderly that's
whatever one quarter of the town's
residents are over 65 fiber keeps them
independent and connected all those
elderly need care entertainment
education permanent etc etc it's about
services and where you can prove this
even to the elderly they are convinced
because it brings quality to our to our
lives
you